اهلا بكم مشاهدينا تغطتنا مستمره
للتداعيات النزاع المسلح في السودان الذي
يعيش مفترق طرق ويمضي في رحله اللعب
اذا الاشتباكات المسلحه في السودان تدخل
يومها الرابع بين قوات الجيش والدعم
السريع هدنه على الطاوله وافق عليها مجلس
السياده السوداني بعد تصريحات لعضو المجلس
شمس الدين كباشه للعربيه اكد فيها ان
المجلس وافق على هدنه مقترحه من الامم
المتحده لمده 24 ساعه تبدا عند السادسه
مساء بشرط ضمان ضبط قوات الدعم سريع مضيفا
بانه سيتم الالتزام بالهدنه ومراقبه مدى
الالتزام من قبل الدعم السريع بها الكباشي
عبر عن اسف مجلس السياده من التصصيد
الحاصل وفشل التهدئه في البلاد مشيرا الى
ان القوات المسلحه كانت مضطره لدخول
المعركه كما كشف عضو مجلس السياده
السوداني ان الانشقاقات داخل الدعم السريع
صحيحه 100% مضيفا بان قوات الدعم السريع
تستعد لاستقبال الطائرات مساعدات في مروي
من جهاته اعلن قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حميتي عبر تغريده له في تويتر عن موافقه
القوات بعقد هدنه لمده 24 ساعه جاء ذلك
لضمان المرور الامن للمدنيين واجلاء
الجرحى بعد اقتراح وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه الفجره اليوم كما قال انه ينتظر
المزيد من المناقشات مع بلينكن حول معالجه
ما وصفه بالانتهاكات التي ارتكبها الجيش
السوداني
الان ونتفاهم به
يمكن هنالك مقترح يمكن تم تقدمه لنا من
المنظمه الامميه وايضا
باتصالات من الدول شقيقه
الامريكي
بوقف اطلاق النار لمده 24
نحن وافقنا على ذلك لمده 24 ساعه فقط
لماذا نظرا للظروف الانسانيه القاتله التي
يعيشها مواطنه
الخط اصبح
ت المستشفيات والخدمات في الكهرباء
والمياه نحتاج لهذه ال 24 ساعه
لسماحه للمواطنين بالحركه
ولجهات الحكوميه المسؤوله بتامين
الاحتياجات اللازمه
من جهتي هكذا يوسف في عز المستشار السياسي
لنائب رئيس مجلس السياده وقائد القوات
الدعم السريع في مقابلات مع العربيه ان
قوات الدعم السريع لا تعترض على الهدنه
وستتصرف بمسؤوليه كامله تجاهها
ذلك
البارحه اتفقنا مع السيد وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي هو الذي اخترع هذه الهدنه وبعد
الدول الصغيره ووافقنا واعطيناه الموافقه
كامله على ان يستجيب الطرف الاخر وللهدنه
واليهود انسانيه
بالامس تم توجيه كل القوات في المواقع
المختلفه قوات الدعم السريع ان تلتزم
بالهدنه وانت تحافظ على المغارات التي
تسيطر عليها ولا تتحرك اي تحرك هجومي او
ان تسهل عبور المدنيين التي نسيطر عليها
هذا هذا كان توجيه واضح من قياده الدعم
السريع بالامس واعلن ذلك اليوم في تغريده
قبل خروج الكباشي او كلامي في نفس الوقت
الساعه الثالثه صباحا نتعرض لهجوم في
القياده العامه التي نسيطر عليها
وقبل ذلك قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكان ان
وقفه اطلاق النار مهم لاهداف انسانيه وقال
ان هذه الهدنه يمكن ان تشكل اساسا للعوده
الى المفاوضات
لقد اجيت اتصالا هذا الصباح بكل من قائد
الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان والفريق محمد
ديجلو حميدتي ودعوتهما لوقف اطلاق النار
لمده 24 ساعه فان وقف اطلاق النار من شانه
ان يشكل اساسا لعوده المفاوضات نتواصل مع
نظرائنا من الامارات والسعوديه وبريطانيا
بشان السودان لقد تعرضت قافله دبلوماسيه
امريكيه امس لاطلاق نار في السودان لكن
جميع الافراد بخير وهذا التصرف طائش وغير
مسؤول
من دبي ينضم الينا سامويل المتحدث
الاقليمي باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه سيد
سامي مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه ابدا
اولا كيف تنظر واشنطن الان لتطورات
الاوضاع على الارض في السودان
اذا شكرا مساء الخير يا خاله وشكرا
للعربيه على الاستضافه وبدون شكل اهم شيء
كما سمعنا من وزير لكن الاهم شيء الان وقف
اطلاق النار وتطبيق الهدنه اذا سمعنا بعض
الوقود سمعنا الكلاب من الجيش السوداني من
قوه الدعم السريع بالنسبه هذه الهدنه
بالنسبه اطلاق النار ولكن امامنا في
الساعه تمامنا لازم نرى فعلا هل هذه
الاطراف السودانيه مستعده لتطبيق
الهوتنهام لان التطبيق الهدنه الاحمشى
الان نحن نرى ان الشعب السوداني يعانون من
يحدد انف من حد التصعيد كثير من المدنيين
قتلوا
وايضا بعض الموظفين في البرامج الغذاء
العالمي قتلوا وكل هذا العنف والتفعيل
يؤدي الى النقص بالنسبه الامكانيه لهذه
المؤسسه الدوليه الانسانيه لايصال
المساعده الانسانيه للشعب السود ونحن نعرف
ان ملايين من الشعب السودانيه اعتمدوا على
المساعده الانسانيه وملايين من السودانيين
يعيشوا خطر جوعا اذا نورت المتحده ترى ان
اهم شيء الان ليوقف اطلاق النار لكن باي
ايه سيتم
تنفيذ هذا الوقت لاطلاق النار من المراقب
من سيشرف على ذلك خاصه انكر على سبيل
المثال كان قال بانه لا يستطيع اصلا
التحرك من مقر اقامته في السودان
اذا كما كنا نقول ان الحل الوحيد يجب ان
يكون حل السوداني السوداني من الازمه
للخدمه ووقف اطلاق النار تكون بين
السودانيين ليس من الممكن المتحده او اي
دوله خارجيه منها الدول في هذه المنطقه
دول في الشرق الاوسط او الخليج او دوله
اوروبيه او الامم المتحده ان تفرض هذا
اللي وقف الاطلاق ناره هذه الهدنه على
الاطراف السودانيه لازم اطراف السودانيه
تقوم بقبول هذه الهدنه وتطبيقها من اجل
السودانيين لازم الجيش السوداني وقوه
الدعم السريه تدعى الشعب السوداني في
اولوياتها وليس هناك خطوات او اليات يجب
القيام بها وفق الرؤيه الامريكيه لذلك سيد
صامويل
معروف ان لدينا بعض الادوات امامنا مثل
متاح لنا مثل العقوبات ومحاسبه ومراقبه
ولكن الان الوقت لنتكلم فقط حول وقف اطلاق
النار امامنا في الايامنا في الاسابيع
امامنا يا خلل ستكون وقت سيكون وقت لنتكلم
محول المحاسبه من مسؤول عن حل العنف من
بضع حد الانف ولكن اليوم نحن نراه في
شاشاتكم وفي كل شاشات اخرى وفي وسائل
الاعلام الاجتماعيه
فيديوهات ماسويه بالنسبه القتل والدمار في
السودان اذا من اللازم اللي اليوم نركز
على هذه الهدنه
ماذا لو فشلت هذه الهدنه او لم يلتزم احد
الاطراف بتنفيذها كيف ستتعامل امريكا مع
هذا الوضع يعني هل ستحمل الطرف المسؤول عن
ذلك المسؤوليه في افشل هذا الاتفاق
نحن نتحمل الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم
السريه مسؤوله عن الوضع الامني والاستقرار
في البلد والانف والتصعيد راينا هذه
الايام ان انا لا اريد ان باي نتيجه لو
فشل او لو نجح هذا الهدنه التركيز هنا
الان تركيز الامريكي والتركيز الموسم
الدولي على نجاح هذه وتطبيق هذه الغزنه
ولذلك نحن في تواصل ليس يومين ولكن كل
دقيقه كل ساعه نعني في التواصل مع كل
الاطراف داخل السودان كما راينا من
الاتصال لكنندي كان عنده الوزير برينكن مع
جامعه برهان وجنوب حميدي وايضا الاتصال
المهم مع كل الدول الاخرى مهمه في هذا
الملف السوداني في المنطقه منها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
وايضا الامم المتحده في البعد الانساني اي
مدى يمكن الاستفاده من هدنه لمده 24 ساعه
سيد سامويل
24 ساعه ليس كافيه لا نحن نريد ان نرى
الولايات المتحده تريد ان ترى عدنا دائم
ووقف اطلاق نار دائم في كل انحاء البلد
و24 ساعه ليس كافيه ولكن من اللازم نحن
نبدا في في نكته لازم نبدا في هذه الهدنه
لو هي هدنه مؤكده اذا نريد ان نبدا في
مكان مناسب واذا هذه الاطراف لديها
لامكانيه لقبول على عهودنا مؤكده 24 ساعه
اوكي نعم لازم نبدا مع هذه النكته ولكن
ولد متحده ترى ان الشعب السوداني الذي كان
يدعه العمليه السياسيه وعمليه ديمقراطيه
تحت قياده مدنيه منذ 2019
يستحقون الخدمه
طيب اريد فقط سيد سامويل ان اشير الى ما
نشاهده الان في زاويه الشاشه
استقبال
لوزير الخارجيه السعودي في دمشق وزياره
العميل فيصل بن فرحان
لدمشق الخارجيه السعوديه تقول
بان هذه زياره تؤكد حرس المملكه على الحل
السياسي السيد صامل
هل هناك بعد مثلا بدايه هذه الهدنه اي
طريق او خطه لايصال مساعدات لضمان تحرك
الناس خلال
بعد فتح الممرات الانسانيه له
هذه النقطه بالنسبه لمباراه الانسانيه
مهمه جدا وعلى كل الاطراف ليس فقط الجيش
السوداني ولكن على كل الاطراف في كل انهاء
البلد لفتح المبارات الانسانيه لسماح
للمؤسسه الدوليه لتعامل
مسؤولياتها وبكل اسف بسبب هذا القتل
وموت ثلاثه اشخاص من البرمج الغذاء
العالميه هذه المؤسسه برنامج الغداء
العالمي قطع
شغلها قتل عملها في البلد
ولذلك من اللازمن كل اطراف السودانيه
لديها الامكانيه للضمان الاستقرار والامن
الكافي لهذه لجعل هذه هي المؤسسات الدوليه
تشعر بالامن كافي لايصال هذه المساعدات
الانسانيه التي الشعب السوداني وانت ما
سيدس ربما تستمع الى اصوات الانفجارات
التي تدور ان السودانيه الخرطوم والسنه
الدخان التي تتصاعد بشكل كثيف من عده
مناطق في اشاره صريحه لتطور الموقف في
الاحتدام المواجهات والاشتباكات العسكريه
الحربيه على اكثر من صعيد سؤالي يعني هل
نسقتم واتصلتم بهذه المنظمات الدوليه
الانسانيه
للقيام بعملها بعد يعني بدايه هذه الهدنه
سيد سامر
نعم اذا نحن كما معروف الولد المتحده من
اكبر او ممكن يكون اكبر مانع منفرد
بالنسبه للمساعده الانسانيه للشعب
السوداني منذ سنوات ونحن سنستمر في ذلك
سنستمر في التنسيق مع الامم المتحده مع
برنامج الغذاء العالمي كل هذه المواساه
الاخرى لايصال المساعده الانسانيه الذي
الشعب السوداني ولكن السؤال امام اطرف
السودانيه الجيش وهذه قوه الدعم هل هي
تسمح لذلك هل هي تسمح المؤسسات الدوليه
لايصال هذه المساعده ليس من الممكن
المتحده او اي دوله اخرى او مؤسسه اخرى
متحده تفرض ذلك على الاطراف السودانيه
ممتاز اثناء الاتصال بين وزير الخارجيه
السيد عبد الفتاح البرهان وكذلك حمايته هل
تعاهد بذلك بالسماح لهذه المنظمات بالتحرك
بحريه بسهوله بسلاسه خلال هذه الفتره ام
لا سيدي
اذا ليس من الممكن ان اتكلم باسم هؤلاء
انا لا اريد ان ادخل في التفاصيل بالنسبه
ما قالوا جنوب برحانه ومقال جنوب حميد
ولكن من جانب نعم نعم بدون شاكل وزير
بلنكن كان يحث على اهميه
ويشد على اهميه ايصال وسماح المساعده
الانسانيه للايصال للشعب السوداني هذا كان
جزء مهم من هذه المناقشات مع جنارين
دبلوماسيه امريكيه لاطلاق نار في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم
كيف ترون ذلك وهل تعرفتم على من كان وراء
هذه الحادثه
نعم اذا حتى الان ما زال نحن بحثت عن كل
التفاصيل ومعلومات من الممكن ان اؤكد ان
السفير الامريكيه هو لم يكن في هذه
القافله او سياراته لم تظهر في هذه الحجوم
وكما سمعنا من وزير بلينكن كانت لدينا كان
لدينا بعض الدلائل او بعض المعلومات التي
تقلنا ان بعض الاشخاص مرتبطه او او
قوه الدعم السريعه كان جزء من هذه الهجوم
ولكن حتى الان هناك تحقيقات انا لا اريد
ان استبق اي نتيجه هذه التحقيقات ولكن نحن
نشد وهذا كان رساله مهمه وقويه من الوزير
الى جنوب برهان وجنى الحميدي ان من اللازم
من هؤلاء يقوم بحمايه وتحمل المسؤوليه
لحمايه ليس فقط الموظفين الملكيين
الدبلوماسيين لا كل الموظفين في كل
السفارات وكل الموظ فين في كل المؤسسه
كل المدنيين السودانيين
سيد صامويل اخيرا الجيش اليوم كان قد تحدث
عن تدخل من دولتين اقليميتين كما قال في
غرب السودان في هذه الحرب بايصال مساعدات
لطرف ما هل لديكم اي معلومات هل لديكم اي
اتصالات وماذا ما هو الموقف الامريكي في
حال ثابته مثل هذا الوضع تدخل دول في هذه
الحرب الان
نشجع اي دوله التي لديها الامكانيه لايصال
مساعده الانسانيه للشعب السوداني للتعامل
ذلك نحن ليسنا تدعي امكانيه او اي محاوله
لايصال وتقديم المسدله الانسانيه للشعب
السوداني نحن في تواصل كما ذكرنا في
التواصل مع كل الدول في المنطقه منها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه والامارات
العربيه المتحده ومصر وكل الدول الاخرى
بنسبه
المحوله لوقف اطلاق النار وايضا اي
امكانيه او الحاجه
لايصال للمساعده الانسانيه للشعب السوداني
هل لديكم اي معلومات حول ما ذهب اليه
البعض من علاقه بما يجري من تطورات في
السودان سيد سامر
منذ زمان منذ شهور منذ سنوات كنا نتكلم يا
استاذ خالد حول الخطر الذي يمثلها هذه
المجموعه مجموعه وكيف وجود هذه المجموعه
في اي بلد تؤدي الى نقص الامكانيه للحكومه
المهنيه
لحمايه مواطنيههم ليقوم باستقرار وامن في
بلادهم اذا ليس هناك اي شيء جديد او
مفاجاه بالنسبه تعثرات السلبيه من مجموعه
نحن اليوم نركز على نوقف اطلاق النار
والهدنه بين الجانبين ولكن بدون مجموعه في
السودان لا تلعب اي دور ايجابي شكرا جزيلا
لك
المتحدث الاقليمي باسم الخارجي الامريكيه
من دبي
[موسيقى]
وعلى صعيد الخدمات الانسانيه قال الاتحاد
الدولي لجمعيات الصليب الاحمر والهلال
الاحمر انه يكاد يكون من المستحيل تقديم
الخدمات الانسانيه في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم وما حولها وحذر من ان النظام
الصحيه في البلاد معرض لخطر الانهيار
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو قال
ان الوضع في السودان اصبح كارثي واكد على
ان امن جميع موظفي الامم المتحده والافراد
المرتبطين بها والعاملين في مجال المساعده
الانسانيه امر ضروري
السودان كان الوضع الانساني في السودان
محفوفا بالمخاطر وهو الان كارثي ادين
الاصابات الجماعيه للمدنيين والعاملين في
المجال الانساني اذكر جميع الاطراف بضروره
احترام القانون الدولي بما في ذلك ضمان
السلامه والامان
من جهتها حتى السفيره الامريكيه لدى الامم
المتحده ليندا
توماسيه في السودان على وقف اطلاق النار
لسماح بالعوده الى المحادثات
نحث الاجهزه الامنيه على اتخاذ خطوات
فعاله للحد من التوتر وضمان سلامه جميع
المدنيين وموظفي الامم المتحده وغيرهم من
الدبلوماسيين والعاملين في المجال
الانساني وقف اطلاق النار هو السبيل
الوحيد لحل القضايا العالقه وضمان وصول
المساعدات الانسانيه واستئناف المفاوضات
لوضع السودان على طريق اتفاق سياسي
من استديوهاتنا في الرياض تنضم الينا
مديره مكتب العربيه في الخرطوم لني يعقوب
اهلا من الخرطوم معنى مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشم يبدا معك سالم اخر المستجدات في
ضوء الحديث عن موافقه من الطرفين على هدنه
انسانيه تبدا في السادسه مساء
سالم
[موسيقى]
نعم نعم سالم كنت اسالك عن اخر التطورات
المستجدات ما زالت لسنه الدخان اصوات
الطلقات والقصف ايضا مدويا في العاصمه
السودانيه مع الان موافقه من الطرفين على
بدايه هدنه انسانيه من السادسه مساء لمده
24 ساعه
نعم يجب ايضا انوه الى هناك العديد من
البيانات التي صدرت خلال اليوم
بيانات كثيره جدا لكن اخر هذه البيانات هو
البيانات الصادر من جهاز المخابرات العامه
الذي اصدر فيه المدير العام لجهاز
المخابرات العامه قرر انها بموجيبه انتداب
جميع الضباط وضباط الصف المنتدبين للعمل
بقوات الدعم السريع ووجه القرار بالانضمام
لاقرب وحده تتبع للاعلام في هذا المخابرات
العامه
لاقرب وحده تتبع لجهاز المخابرات العامه
وهذا البيان خازن من مدير اعلام جهاز
المخابرات العامه هذه البيانات ظلت تتوالى
في الساعات الماضيه في بيانات منفصله
وايضا كان هناك بيان لوزاره الخارجيه التي
ناشدت فيه كذلك المجتمع الدولي بعدما
التعامل مع هذه القوه
المتمرده على الجيش السوداني بحسب وصفه
وصفه
الخارجيه السودانيه ايضا هناك جبريل
ابراهيم وهو يدعو القوات المسلحه والدعم
السريع الاحترام لمده 24 ساعه
وجبريل ابراهيم هو الان وزير الماليه
السوداني وهو
قائد حركه العدل والمساواه السودانيه
الموقع على اتفاق جبال السلام وربما هذه
اخر تحديثات فيما يتعلق بالبيانات التي
هل من مؤشرات على امكانيه التزام الطرفين
بهذه الهدنه
يعني هناك استعدادات يعني الهدنه من قبل
المواطنين هذا الامر بانه ينتظرون هذه
الصبر ليذهبوا لشرائح احتياجاتهم
من الاسواق ويجتهد في الوصول الى اماكنهم
كذلك لانه هناك يعني انقطاع تام بسبب
انقطاع الطرق في هذه الحرب التي اندلعت
منذ ثلاثه ايام كانت هناك صعوبه في التنقل
فربما هذه تشاهد في مساله التنقل هذه كما
يغني المواطنين انفسهم بانتهاء الازمات
التي ظهرت في هذه الايام
كازمه المياه وندرس بعض بعض السلعه كذلك
هل هناك ممرات انسانيه يعني محدده
يمكن الحديث عنها بالاتفاق بين الطرفين
لبدء يعني تفعيلها اثناء هذه الهدنه
لا يوجد حتى الان الحديث عن طريقه لتنفيذ
هذه الهدنه من الجانبين نقصد من الدعم
السريع والجيش فقط هم نوه تنويه
يعني عام عنوان رئيس لانهم سيلتزمون بوقت
اطلاق النار في ال24 ساعه منذ سادسه وهذا
هو العنوان الابرز بعد ذلك على الارض ربما
هنا تكون هنالك ادوار
للمجتمع ادوار
للجهات الفاعله في هذا المجتمع ايا كانت
هذه المظلات التي تعمل تحتها من اجل تنظيم
الحركه حركه الناس وحتى اخبار الناس وهناك
حملات كرويه من الشباب في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي
في التعامل مع مع اطلاق النار حينما يقول
في التعامل مع الازمات نفسها الان هناك
حملات تطلق الان في مساله نجره المياه
الموجوده الان في التبليغ عن الاماكن التي
توجد فيها المياه ونقل هذه المياه
للمواطنين
هذه هي الان بدات تعمل وربما تنتعش في هذه
الفتره فتره الهدنه في 24 ساعه التفكير
الناس يعني في استفاده من هذه الهدنه اللي
هو على جلب يعني
الغذاء الدواء الماء ام ان هناك من يفكر
فعليا في الخروج من الخرطوم
حقيقه ايضا تختلف وجهات النظر هنا في
مساله الخروج من الخرطوم من عدمها
ربما تشهد الخرطوم يعني نجوحا هذا متوقع
في ظل هذه الازمه لكن المؤكد ان هناك جهات
يعني ستجتهد في توصيل هذه السلع التي بدات
في الندره وايصال كذلك في هذه الفتره ايضا
الفتره 24 ساعه وايضا سيجتهد المواطنون
على الاقل المقيمين بالخرطوم الذين
سيكونون في الخرطوم بتوفير احتياجاتهم
الضروريه لفترات طويله وهذا امر متوقعه
وارد جدا في ال24 ساعه القادمه شكرا جزيلا
لك براس العربيه سالم الهاشمي من الخرطوم
قد نعود اليك لاحقا في ثنايا هذه الن
شر لنرحبا مجددا
لا مراقبين حسب السيد صامل لا احد يمكن ان
يشرف على تنفيذ هذه الهدنه
فبالتالي الامر متروك للسودانيين يعني الى
قوات الدعم السريع والجيش هل انت متفائله
بامكانيه تنفيذها هذه الهدنه فيها كثير من
الخطوره الهدنه تعني ايقاف اطلاق النار
عدم اعتراض المواطنين في الشارع عدم
ايقافهم ايضا السماح لهم بالحركه بل
ومساعدتهم الخروج من الاماكن التي تمت
محاصرتهم فيها سواء كانت في مؤسسات
اكاديميه تعليميه في بعض المقر الحكوميه
بان يتحركوا بحريتهم هناك اسر مثلا هي
تسكن في منطقه ام درمان هي الان عالقه في
بحري او عالقه في الخرطوم نسبه لاغلاق
الجسور فهل سيشعر المواطنين
بحريه الحركه داخل العاصمه وداخل الولايات
السودانيه في خلال هذه الهدنه الهدنه لا
تعني فقط عدم الاستماع لاصوات اطلاق
الرصاص هي تعني امان لدى المواطن بان
يمارس حياته بشكل طبيعي وهذا الامر لا
يبدو واضح لان الانتشار كل المشاهد التي
تاتي الان والتي تظهر الان تؤكد بصوره
واضحه ان الانتشار موجود للجيش في كثير من
الشوارع وان الدعم السريع ايضا متواجد في
شوارع اخرى وحتى مساله الممرات الانسانيه
لا معلومات لا احد يعرف ان كانت كل
الممرات ستفتح او انها ستكون هناك مرات
محدده يمكن للناس من خلالها ان تتحرك ايضا
الينا كيف ترين الان نعم هي كلمه الممرات
الامنه خالد كانت تستخدم في ولايات
سودانيه حينما كانت الحكومه السودانيه
تمنع الاغاثه الوصول الى مناطق في جنوب
كردفان والنيل الازرق ودارفور
استخدام كلمه ممرات امنه هي جديده على
المستمع السوداني في العاصمه الخرطوم ما
هي هذه الممرات الامنه لا احد يعلم لكن ما
نعلمه ان الممر الامن هو حريه الحركه في
الشارع في الاحياء في المناطق السكنيه وهو
الامر الذي قد يهدد انا اعتقد ان هذه
الهدنه هي اختبار والشارع السوداني يريد
ان يرى كيف ستكون هذه الهدنه ان التزمت
الاطراف بعدم اطلاق النار بان تسمح
للمواطنين بالتحرك بحريه داخل الشوارع بان
يشعر اصحاب المحاله التجاريه انهم قادرين
على الذهاب الى محالهم اعتقد ان الهدنه في
هذه الحاله تنجح لانها لا تعني فقط وقف
اطلاق النار هل يمكن لاي طرف في الداخل
السوداني ان يلعب دور الضامن لهذه لتنفيذ
هذه الهدنه في طوخيه اي دور دولي لذلك كما
شار السيد سامو قبل قليل طبعا خالد يمكن
ولكن هناك معضله حقيقيه تقف امام هذه
الهدنه يعني ان استمعت لاصوات اطلاق النار
الدعم السريع سيقول ان الجيش هو الذي اطلق
النار سيقول ان الدعم السريع اطلق المال
ليس لدى القوه السياسيه او لداء المراقبين
اي وسيله للتاكد من الذي بدا هذه الاصوات
الان يسمعها الناس لكنهم لا يدرون من اين
تصدر ومن البادئ ومن المخطئ ومن الذي رد
هي بيانات الان تصدر من الجيش والدعم
السريع ضد بعضهما ولكن وسيله التحقق هنا
صعبه
وان تم خرق هذه الهدنه اول بيان سيصدر من
الجيش يتحدث عن خلق الهدنه من قبل الدعم
السريع والدعم السريع سيتحدث ان هذه
الهدنه خلقت لان الجيش لم يلتزم بها
بالتالي وسيله التحقق في هذه الحاله صعب
للغايه
من خلال متابعتك لردود الافعال من قبل
شارع السوداني السودانيين والمواطنين
العاديين على هذه الهدنه كيف راي تيها لنا
الشارع السوداني سيسعد بوجود هدنه لانه
كما ذكرت لك هناك نقص في الكهرباء نقص في
خدمه المياه وهناك تعطل في كثير من
المحطات ايضا هناك نقص في الامداد الغذائي
في كثير من المحل التجاريه الان هناك
عالقين وهو امر صعب وهناك جثث موجوده في
اماكن لا يستطيع الاسر الوصول اليها او
اخذها او دفنها لذلك اضطرت احدى الجامعات
السودانيه بان تدفن طالب داخل الجامعه
وهذا امر جديد على الشارع السوداني حتى
يعتاد على مثل هذه الامور لكنه سيترق
جميعنا سنترقب هذه الهدنه هل سنستمع الى
اصوات اطلاقنا هل سيشعر المواطنين بحريه
في الحركه في خلال هذه الايام الاخيره من
شهر رمضان ام لا هل من بغلق الان عند شارع
السوداني في حاله عدم الالتزام
اي طرف تدفعهم ربما الى موجات نزوح او
هروب جماعي في العاصمه الخرطوم على الاقل
في بدايه ساعه الاولى لهذه
لا اظ
ن ان كان المطار يعمل ان تسافر اسر للخارج
لان كثير من الاسل السودانيه لديها ابناء
في الخارج كان يمكن ان يكون هذا احد
الحلول خاصه ان هناك كبار السن وهناك مرضى
فشيء طبيعي ان تنتقل الاسر وتسافر الى
الخارج ولكن طالما ان الملاحه الجويه
تعطلت وقد ايضا تتعطل الملاحه البحريه
لانها توقفت او توقفت ايضا حركه السفن
كذلك الحركه البريه وحركه السيارات
والشاحنات والباصات كلها معقده الان في ظل
هذا الوضع لذلك لا يمكن ان يفكر
السودانيين في هذه الموجه ولا توجد اصلا
وسيله حتى يفكر فيها في ظل هذا الحصار
الموضوع بسبب هذه الحرب شكرا جزيلا لك من
مديره مكتب العربيه في الخرطوم شكرا
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر لسه لسه
الليله ان شاء الله ما في اي خائن في
البلد دي
[موسيقى]
كويس
وعلى صعيد المعاناه الصحيه التي يعيشها
السودان كذا تاكدت نقابه الاطباء على تضرر
المبنى الاداري ومبنى الحوادث وخزان
المياه في مستشفى الشعب ودانت نقابه
الاطباء قصبه مستشفى الشعب بالطيران الذي
تم ضرب المبنى الاداري ومبنى الحوادث
وصهريج المياه والصهريج مياه مستشفى
الخرطوم وسكن الممرضات في مستشفى ابن سينا
الجامعي مضيفه بان استهداف البنيه التحتيه
للمستشفيات عمل تمتد اثاره لسنوات القادمه
حيث سيفاقم انهيار الخدمات او انهيار
الخدمات الصحيه المنهاره قوات الدعم
السريعه اتهمت قياده القوات المسلحه
بالتوجيه ضربه عسكريه بالطيران الحربي
للدائره الطبيه لقوات الدعم السريع التي
تقع داخل نطاق تواجد المدنيات المدنيين
بحي شمبات في مدينه بحري قد استهدفت
الضربه العسكريه اسرى القوات المسلحه
والمصابين من الطرفين والمدنيين الذين
يتلقون المساعدات الطبيه والانسانيه داخل
مستشفى الدائره الطبيه
اهلا وسهلا بك
هل سيلتزم الطرفان بتنفيذ هذه الهدنه
في الحقيقه يعني
الاجابه على هذا السؤال يعني تتضمن بعد
اخر يعني احنا اهم شيء في انه التزام
الطرفان انه
استفاده الجانب المدني من هذه الهدنه يعني
وانا اعتقد الالتزام لن ياتي الا على ارض
الواقع يعني من خلال تجارب سابقه يعني
السودان مرت في حروب طويله يعني مثل هذا
الامر هل عدم وجود اللا رقابه ولا يعني
اشراف على التنفيذ من اي طرف ثالث اخر هل
بالفعل يمكن ان تكون هناك اشراف يعني
اشراف من مكثفه على ارض الواقع لن تنجح
هذه الهدنه كما تعلم اخي خالد
الخرطوم هي العاصمه الوحيده في العالم
اللي هي مشكلة من ثلاثه مدن جغرافيا هي
اكثر من 8 ملايين
نسمه ومتباعده الاطراف والبهن التحتيه
فيها يعني متباعده جدا حتى نعتقد انه 8
صغير كافيه بالضبط يعني هذه الاوضاع في ظل
وجود جثث يعني منتشره في شوارع مبعثره وفي
ظل انقطاع الكهرباء والمياه لابد ان تكون
هنالك فرق
واعادتها هؤلاء العمال المتخصصين لاعاده
خدمات المياه هذا يحتاج لوقت كبير
والكهرباء يعني زيد على ذلك الطوائم
الطبيه كلها اخرجت من كثير من المستشفيات
يعني في اكبر مستشفيات في الخرطوم اخليت
تماما يامن من قبل قوات الدعم السريع او
من القوات الجيش السوداني لظروف عسكريه او
امنيه القصد منها يعني
اخلاء هذه المواقع لملاحقه بعض القوات من
الطرفين يعني فكل هذه الظروف انا اعتقد 24
ساعه غير كافيه في ظل عدم وجود من المسؤول
عن يعني تنفيذ او او الاشراف او الرقابه
على هذه السوداني الدعم السريع لحد الان
لم يطلع يعني انا اعتقد حتى الجهه التي
طلبت الهدنه اذا كانت الخارجيه الامريكيه
اول امم المتحده لم توضح خطتها
اليه هو المتحدث باسم الخارجيه قال لي ان
الامر متروك للسودانيين
يعني لا اعتقد انه يعني تنجح هذه الهدنه
ولا اعتقد انه لن تستمر يعني ساعات يعني
واذا اخذناه من ناحيه ايجابيه الى اي مدى
يمكن ان تنعكس عندما تم تنفيذها على
الحاله الانسانيه التي تمر بها الخرطوم في
اكثر مجال مساله الوضع الصحي المتفاقم
ربما
نقص الغذاء نقص الدواء انتشار الجثث في
الارض ما الذي يمكنني ان يتغير
يعني حسب الاحصائيات الان المتوفره من
هيئه الصليب الاحمر هنالك اكثر من 1800
جريح وفي نحو
185 قتيل وانتم كما ذكرتم في بعض اخباركم
كيف يعني الطلاب المحتجزين من كليه
الهندسه بجمع قرطوم دفنوا احد في داخل
الميدان الغربي يعني لم يستطيعوا ان
يخرجوا انا اعتقد انه يعني
انا زي ما ذكرت لك انا بصير على انه 24
ساعه كافيه لتبدا من الساعه السادسه يوم
الثلاثاء وتنتهي للسادسه غير كافيه لضم
الجراحه التي افرزتها هذه الحرب خلال مده
اربعه ايام يعني
يمكن البناء عليه
الضعيفه والبنيه التحتيه لمدينه الخرطوم
باذن الله لا توجد هناك متر ولا توجد بساط
عامله حتى انه المحطات البنزين قد اغلقت
يعني كل هذه يعني وسائل النقل ضعيفه حتى
يعني يستطيع الناس ان الزمن للاستفاده من
من من هذا الوقت يعني في ظل كما ذكرت انت
ان ليست هنالك جهه اشرافيه معينه تشرف على
مرور هذه المسارات الامنه انا اعتقد كله
طرف حيكون له راي يعني لانه بمعنى كيف كله
طرف لانه
عدم الثقه بين الطرفين قد انت تستغل هذه
الوقت لتمرير بعض المواد الزخيره المواد
التموينيه للطرفات تمرير الجنود الان انا
بشوف يعني قبل قليل في مقطع في المواطنه
انه في الجيش السوداني يبدو يستعين ببعض
القوات في خارج الخرطوم للدخول يعني يمكن
المناطق التي يستفيدنا الجيش السوداني انه
واللي هو كسل بورسودان عبر مدني هذه المدن
القريبه الجغرافيا يستطيع الجن السوداني
ان يعني مستعين بجنود من من هذه الحاميات
كما ذكر قال احنا يعني خطرتنا المرحليه
انه سوف نستمر فيها حتى يعني ياخذ الجنود
الذين كانوا في المواجهه يعني في في
البدايه المعركه ان يستبدلوا بجدود اخرين
ما خطوره ادم تنفيذ هذه الهدنه انا اعتقد
انه الوضع سوف يكون كارثي كيف
كارثه في انه في استمرار عدم معالجه الجرح
الوضع
الناحيه البيئيه يعني وجود الجثث مندثره
في الشوارع هذا امر خطير جدا يعني والناس
الان تشتم رائحه الموت واعتقد هذه جانبيه
مهمه في ظل وجود عدم مواد تموينيه الان لو
شاهدت المشاهد البقالات خلاص كل المواد
التموينيه استنتجت تماما في ظل الان انتم
ممكن نقلتوا انتوا الان تم حرق اكبر سوق
رئيسي في الخرطوم بحري
هذا هذا فيه خطوره جدا يعني امدادات
التمويل الكهرباء المياه في بعض السكان
مما بدت هذه
في المواجهات ليس لديها منقطع بها المياه
يعني فهذه هذه هنا تم
واضح شكرا جزيلا لك الكاتب الصحفي محمود
العوده شكرا
وسط روايات المتضاربه من الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريعه فادت الاخيره بانها
سيطرت على مطار الخرطوم الدولي في العاصمه
السودانيه مع اندلاع الاشتباكات مع الجيش
[تصفيق]
الان بمطار
الخرطوم المدني
وهذه ايضا صور ملتقطه بالاقمار الصناعيه
تظهر حجم الدمار الذي لحق بمطاره الخرطوم
او مروي وتعرض صور مشاهده لطائرات مدنيه
وعسكريه مدمره بالاضافه الى لقطات لاعمده
النيران الناجمه عن الحرائق
مطارات السودان اذا كانت ساحه معركه مبكره
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في هذا
العرض نتعرف على ابرز مطارات البلاد التي
تدور فيها وحولها المعارك
اهميه استراتيجيه تحظى بها المطارات في اي
نزاع مسلح والوضع في السودان ليس استثناء
لهذه الاهميه في قلب الخرطوم يقع مطار
العاصمه وهو الاكبر في السودان انشئ
المطار عام
1947 ومر بعده عمليات توسعه واعاده تاهيل
حتى بات مركزا ل 95% من حركه الطيران
الخارجيه في الاشتباكات الحاليه في
السودان كان مطار الخرطوم محور رئيسيا
للاقتتال بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع خاصه وان المطار مدني وترتبط به
قاعده عسكريه جويه
اهميه اخرى يحظى بها مطار الابيض في
المدينه التي تحمل ذات الاسم على بعد 450
كيلو مترا غرب الخرطوم فالمطار نقطه وصل
بين العاصمه ومعظم مناطق دارفور كما انه
مركز لقوات حفظ السلام الامميه في منطقه
ابياي المتنازع عليها بين السودان ودوله
جنوب السودان
اخيرا الى مطار مروي الواقع في الولايه
الشماليه وتتداخل فيه الاهميه الاقتصاديه
بالعسكريه هذا المطار كان من المشاريع
المصاحبه لانشاء خزان او سد مروي للاهميه
في الري وتوليد الكهرباء وكما هو الحال
بالنسبه لمطار الخرطوم يحتوي مطار مروي
بدوره على قاعده جويه
من القاهره ينضم الينا الدكتور محمد
الزيات مستشار المركز المصري للفكر
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه ايضا من القاهره
معنا الدكتور محمد عز الدين رئيس مؤسسه
النيل للدراسات الافريقيه والاستراتيجيه
ابدا معك دكتور محمد مجاهد اهلا وسهلا بك
معي كيف تتابع ولا القاهره ما يحدث من
تطورات في السودان الى اي مذاهيه تتعامل
الان
بجديه مع التطورات
تحياتي استاذ خالد مصر تعتبر من اكثر
الدول الجوار التي تهتم بالتطورات
السودانيه الجاريه وهي اكثر الدول المعنيه
بتحقيق الاستقرار والامن في السودان لسبب
بسيط انه الامن السوداني جزء اساسي من
الامن القومي المصري ما حدث الان هو صراع
عسكري وازمه مركبه اضافت الازمه السودانيه
التي يعاني منها السودان منذ فتره الخشيه
المصريه من ان تستمر هذه المواجهات
العسكريه واصبحوا هناك واقع على الارض لم
يكن موجودا الواقع الجديد يقول ان هناك
انقساما حادا في المؤسسه العسكريه
السودانيه يصعب حله بسهوله ويسعوا
بالتفاوض عليه في ظل هذا الواقع الخوف
بالنسبه لمصر ان يستمر هذا الصراع العسكري
وامتد وينتشر على اتساع السودان وهو يفتح
الباب الى دخول قوى مناهضه هناك على
امتداد السودان الى منطقه الساحل والصحراء
اكبر اكبر مناطق التمركز الحالي بنسبه
لتنظيم القاعده وتنظيم داعش هناك حراج
دولي كبير لمواجهه وتنتشر بدء الفصائل
التابعه للتنظيمين في دول الجوار او في
المناطق التي لا تخضع للسيطره ودبما تمتد
الى السودان هنا يصبح الخطر يعني وجودي
بالنسبه للدوله المصريه التي نجحت في
تامين حدودها الغربيه على امتداد سنوات مع
ليبيا والقوه الصديقه هناك وتعود مره اخرى
الى الجبهه الجنوبيه اذا مصر هي اكثر
الدول الاقليميه المعنيه بالاستقرار في
السودان
تجري اتصالاتها المتواصله منذ اليوم الاول
مع طرفي الصراع ومع القوى
المعنيه سواء اقليميه او دوليه للوصول الى
عمليه وقف اطلاق نار يكون حقيقي ولكن
الواقع على الارض والتحولات التي جرت يجعل
من الصعب التصور الى تحقيق هذا الهدف خلال
هذه الايام
دكتور محمد الضيفي ايضا من القاهره محمد
عز الدين
هناك جدل كبير صاحب موضوع الكشف عن وجود
عدد من الجنود المصريين في قاعده عسكريه
بالسودان بشان اسباب تواجدهم هناك بشان
كذلك الموقف بعد ذلك
مما حصل يعني
في تصريحات تلفزيونيه كان قائد قوات الدعم
السريع الفريق محمد حمدانو قال ان قوته
مستعده للتعاون مع مصر لتسهيل عوده الجنود
المصريين الذين سلموا انفسهم
لقوته في مدينه مروي
من وضع يعني القانوني اولا لهؤلاء الجنود
وكيف يتعامل معهم التعامل معهم المؤسسات
ذات العلاقه الان مع مع تواجدهم الان في
في السودان
طيب استاذ خالد اولا احييك
ثانيا وجود وجود القوات المصريه داخل
السودان والتعاون المصري السوداني من خلال
قوات البلدين هي يعني علاقه تاريخيه بدات
منذ اكثر من 100 سنه يعني عندما تاسس
الجيشين هناك علاقات وطيده بين الجيشين
هناك توامه حقيقيه بين الجيشين هناك تعاون
هناك تدريبات مشتركه اليوم وانا احدثك
هناك كان هناك بعض
الظباط يتدربون في عدد من الاكاديميات
الحربيه في مصر وهم سودانيين فبالتالي
وجود قوات مصريه داخل السودان هذا ليس
بغريب هي
بروتوكول متفق عليه
لتبادل الخبرات والتدريب
ما بينهم في مطار مروي
وخاصه ان عدد القوات الموجوده ليست يعني
القوات التي يعني
بشكوك ان هناك محاوله لاحتلال او غير او
غير مثلما سوق له
قوات الدعم السريع قبل اقتحام مطار مروي
للاسف الشديد استاذ خالد
منذ الثوره السودانيه وهناك محاولات
الاستقطاب الشباب في الشارع السوداني
باستعداء مصر وبمحاوله خلق عدوه في الشمال
السوداني وهي مصر
والتسويق ان مصر تاخذ من السودان وخيراتها
ومقدراتها على عكس ذلك يعني اذا تحدثنا
بالارقام مصر
الحركه التجاريه ما بين مصر والسودان مصر
تصدر باكثر من 450 مليون دولار سنويا
للسودان والسودان تصدر لمصر كل ذلك مفهوم
فبالتالي الجنود هؤلاء جاءوا الى بالتاكيد
بالموافقه من الحكومه السودانيه وبالترتيب
بالموا
فقه فضلا مختلف يعني ومع وجودهم مع الطرف
يواجه الان او يحارب الان من كانت حكومه
في يوم من الايام
للاسف الشديد يعني انا اعتقد ان ان تم
استدراج حمتي
بانه باسترضاء الشارع السوداني من خلال
استعداد القوات المصريه الموجوده في مروي
للبروتوكول التدريبات المشتركه ما بين
البلدين وهذه ليست المره الاولى ولا
الاخيره كان هناك عده مناورات مشتركه ما
بين القوات المصريه والقوات السودانيه
خاصه في مجال الطيران وكان هناك مناوره ما
يسمى نسور النيل واحد ونسور النيله اثنين
فبالتالي تم استدراج حماتي لاسترضاء
الشارع من خلال بعض الاحزاب التي اقنعته
عندما نسوق لوجود جنود مصريين في في سد في
في مطار مروي ومحاوله اقتحامك هذا سيعطي
لك عدد من الاصوات والشعبيه في الشارع
السوداني ومنه تصل الى حكم السودان هل
يمكن ان يكون هؤلاء الجنود سيد دكتور محمد
مجاهد الزيات يعني مساله تستغلها بعض
الاطراف في السودان الابتزاز الحكومه
المصريه على اعتبار ما ذهب اليه البعض من
توصيفهم كرهانه وكاسرى حرب كما يقول يذهب
بعض اخر
استاذ خالد هذه ليست قوات هي ثريه صغيره
اسمها سريه اسناد مجموعه من من العسكريين
الفنيين الذين يتواجدون الى جانب عدد من
الطائرات شاركت في مناورات وتستعد
لمناورات اخرى فتقدم عمليه الاسناد الخاصه
بالطائرات التي تعداد للدخول في المناوره
هذه القوات اجرت ثلاث مناورات وللعلم كانت
هناك مناورات اشتركت فيها قوات سعوديه
وكانت على ارض المطار طائرات عسكريه
سعوديه اثناء المناره لا توجد لا يعقل ان
تذهب قوات مصريه لتحتل السودان بسريه من
الفنيين لا يوجد فيهم سوى ضابط واحد قال
العلم عدد الضباط والجنود السودانيين
الموجودين في مصر اضعاف هذه القوه النقطه
الثانيه لا يمكن لاحد ان يساوم مصر على
هذه القوه ولعلك لاحظت ان حميدتي قد غير
موقفه 180 درجه صح يا محاوله استثمار هذا
الموقف في البدايه وتحدث عن طائرات مجهوله
تضرب قوات ه في بورسودان وهو غير حقيقي
لكنه عاد مره اخرى الى صوابه وتاكد على ان
انه يجري الان البحث عن وسيله لعوده
القوات المصريه الى مصر
في في في تصورات او سيناريوهات هذه الحرب
اذا امتدت اذا فشلت هذه الهدنه اذا استمرت
هذه الحرب لفتره اطول ما هي حسابات
القاهره دكتور محمد الزيات الى اي حد يمكن
ان تدخل على خط هذه الازمه في السودان
حمايه لمصالحها بالتاكيد
اوضح اليوم موقفا لابسه فيه ان مصر لن
تتدخل في الشؤون الداخليه للسودان هذا هو
المنطق الذي يحكمها ويحكمها منذ سنوات
طويله رغم دعاوى بعض القوى السياسيه في
السودان التي تحاول الهروب من واقعها ومن
الازمه المركبه داخلها للبحث عن سبب خارجي
لكن عندما لم استمرت هذه المعارك ووصلت
الى حرب شوارع ودخلت الى داخل السودان
مجموعات ارهابيه في هذه الحاله لابد ان
يكون هناك تحرك مصري لتامين حدودها فقط
لكن لا لن تتورط مصر في الازمه الداخليه
في السودان ولن تنحاز مصر الى طرف من
الاطراف لمواجهه الطرف الاخر ولن يدخل
جندي مصري في تاكيد بناء على الموقف
المصري الذي تقريبا وضح خلال اجتماع
المجلس الاعلى للقوات المسلحه بالامس ان
تتدخل في العمليه لكنها على الاقل ستتخذ
اجراءات التي تكفل تامين الحدود المصريه
وعدم انسحاب العمليات العسكريه الى
اراضيها
دكتور محمد ما رايك ستكون هناك يعني
اجتماع تشاوري
للجامعه العربيه
في طلب ايضا سعودي ومصري لمناقشه موضوع
السودان ما الذي يمكن ان يخرج به هذا
الاجتماعيه
يعيد دورا عربيا للازمه السودانيه كانوا
مفتقدا منذ سنوات الاتحاد الافريقي يتحرك
بصوره كبيره داخل الازمه ويشكل وفدا
للتباحث مع الطرفيه الصراع والجمال
العربيه غائبه عن الموقف الا في بعض
البيانات ربما يصدر عن هذا المؤتمر مبادره
ما تجمع الاطراف العربيه الاقليميه ذات
الصله بطرفه الصراع الموجوده وبالقوه
السياسيه السودانيه على على اختلافها وطرح
صيغه للتوفيق بين الطرفين وان كنت ارى ان
حل الازمه السودانيه او وقف العمليات
العسكريه لن يكون سهلا في ظل سعي كل طرف
الاستئصال الطرف الاخر وفي ظل الواقع
الجديد الذي ترتب على الخسائر المتبادله
بين الطرفين وهو ما يحتاج الى جهد مضاعف
من القوه الاقليميه المؤثره والتي تملك
التاثير على طرفي الصراع
دكتور محمد دعزه
رايك في
مساله امتداد هذه الازمه وان كان هناك
اطراف دوليه مستفيده من هذه الحرب
واستمرارها لفتره اطول ربما ان تصل الى
سيناريو مشابه لما حدث في ليبيا او في
سوريا
ما مدى خطوره هذا الامر وكيف يجب مواجهته
ايضا
لا بد
مواجهه
لا بد من مواجهه فشل الدوله السودانيه
بالاقتتال من خلال جامعه الدول العربيه
ومن خلال عدد من الدول الهامه عربيا مثل
السعوديه والامارات بالتعاون المصري
والجنوب السوداني اعتقد ان الرباعيه هذه
تكون افضل من الرباعيه سابقتها خاصه ان
الدولتين هامتين بالنسبه للسودان ستشترك
مثل مصر وجنوب السودان ودولتين عربيتين
كبيرتين لهما تعاون كبير
الصرع في مصالحهم في السودان في هذه
الازمه
بالطبع حتى لو لم يتفقوا
السعوديه لها علاقات مع القوات مع الجيش
السوداني ولا علاقات مع حماتي الامارات له
علاقات مع الجيش السوداني ولو علاقات مع
حماتي كذلك مصر وله اتصالات فبالتالي
اعتقد ان العرب لا بد ان يتفقوا هذه المره
بان يخرجوا
باتفاق على ان لن على ان لا يظبطوا حتى
تفشل الدوله السودانيه مثل مثلما حدث بصمت
عربي في ليبيا وبصمت عربي في سوريا وبصمت
عربي في اكثر من دوله عربيه اخرى اعتقد
السيناريوه تقسيم السودان مطروح بقوه
للاسف الشديد يعني اقولها وانا حزين
تقسيم السودان اذا استمرت خطيره جدا هذه
القوات اتت من الهامش
وستعود الى الهامش وسيكون لها بقعه
جغرافيه واعتقد انها ستختار دارفور معقلها
ثم تقاتل من من خلالها
وتصل الى دوله
مقتطعه من السودان شكرا جزيلا لك محمد عز
الدين الدكتور محمد عز الدين رئيس مؤسسه
النيل للدراسات الافريقيه والاستراتيجيه
طيب في ايضا من القاهره الدكتور محمد
الزيات مستشار المركز المصري للفكر
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه
نبقى ايضا في مصر حيث عبر مواطنون
سودانيون عن غضبهم وحزنهم لاستمرار
المواجهات الداميه بين قوات الجيش والدعم
السريع وطالبوا بضروره وقف اطلاق النار
والاستجابه الفوريه لجميع مبادره التهدئه
هنا في حاله الصوفي في احدى ضواحي منطقه
وسط البلد في العاصمه القاهره تعكس ملامح
وجوه ابناء الجاليه السودانيه علامات حزن
واسع العيون تتوجه لشاشات التلفاز
والهواتف النقاله لمتابعه اخبار
الاشتباكات الداميه في السودان والحديث لا
يتوقف عن مجريات القتل والخراب
الدنيا رمضان يعني في حد في رمضان بيحارب
يوقف حرب الناس مساكين ما فيش كهرباء ما
فيش مويه يعني احنا ما واقفين مع الجيش
ولا واقفين مع حماتي نحن عايزين نحد اللحم
والسودان يد واحده اغلب من التقيناهم لم
يخفوا حزنهم وغضبهم الجميع يحاول ان
يتواصل مع الاهل والاقارب للاطمئنان على
سلامتهم
يعني ما قادرين ينوموا حتى
بس ربنا يكون في عونه ان شاء الله يا رب
الكثيرون عبروا عن املهم في ان تنجح
المناشدات والمحاولات العربيه والاقليميه
والدوليه للوصول الى وقف لاطلاق النار
والحد من نزيف الدماء نتمنى من اخواننا
العرب منطقه الجاليه العربيه كل ما يجفهم
معنا في كل شيء ان شاء الله يا رب
العالمين نرجح كل المجتمع الدولي
والاقليمي
تقف وقفه واحده اتجاه خروج من الازمه
الحاليه هسه حاليا قاعد في الخرطوم
الاحداث وتداعياتها اثرت على مجموعات
كبيره من السودانيين والمصريين العاملين
في مجالات النقد البري بين البلدين شغل
بتاعنا الضرر من 3 ايام بالضبط او من اربع
ايام الواد اختلف كان مثلا ومعايا عربيه
ومعايا واحد صاحبي معي عربيه بنشيل شغل
بنودي شغل الشغل من العادم بقى له اربع
ايام عدد ابناء الجاليه السودانيه في مصر
يتراوح ما بين خمسه الى ثمانيه ملايين
نسمه رقم مرشح للزياده في حال استمرار ت
دهور الاوضاع السياسيه والامنيه
والاقتصاديه احمد عثمان العربيه القاهره
اذا نعتذر من تغطيتنا المستمره ايضا على
شاشه العربيه للتطورات الازمه في السودان
الزميله ميسون عزام تلتقيكم على راس
الساعه انا اودعكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات